nous sommes à nice sur le fameux cours
saleya
à l'occasion du salon du livre de la
ville dont c'est cette année la deuxième
édition
et puisque vient l'été saison souvent
propice aux plaisirs de la lecture j'ai
choisi de vous parler du dernier livre
de philippe delerm la première gorgée de
bière et autres plaisirs minuscules qui
paraît aux éditions de l'arpenteur et
qui constitue un mur catalogue
d'agrément quotidien et gratuit l'auteur
est né à auvers-sur-oise où vécut van
gogh
il a 47 ans et enseigne en normandie
delerm possède une façon bien à lui de
décrire les bonheur ordinaire qui n'est
pas sans rappeler celle d'un autre
écrivain normand très grand et très
méconnu jean paul personne avant lui
n'avait eu l'idée de décrire cette
sensation si particulière que l'on
éprouve lorsque l'on écosse des petits
pois la cueillette des mûres à la fin de
l'été les vieux compartiments de chemin
de fer avec miroir et paysages de france
l'odeur des pommes dans l'art sert la
lecture du journal au petit déjeuner ce
sont là des plaisirs accessible qui
souvent met en jeu le goût de l'enfance
mais aussi le présent ce bel aujourd'hui
qui nous est offert de partager